ahora sí ya estamos listos para estudiar
el análisis de circuitos y bueno para
empezar a diseñar circuitos y
analizarlos una de las cosas que
necesitamos es tener cosas con las
cuales construir los circuitos y eso es
justo de lo que vamos a hablar en este
vídeo la idea principal es que tenemos
tres elementos distintos en los
circuitos a los que les llamamos
resistor que bueno a los resistor es
comúnmente también se les llama como
resistencias entonces a veces les
llamaremos resistor es y a veces
resistencias luego también tenemos a los
capacitores aunque también son conocidos
como condensadores eléctricos y
finalmente tenemos a los inductores
también conocidos como reactores aunque
hay estos son los tres componentes
pasivos que vamos a utilizar para
diseñar todo tipo de circuitos aunque
primero te quiero enseñar qué símbolo
utilizamos para referirnos a cada uno de
estos componentes y utilizamos esos
símbolos cuando estamos dibujando a los
circuitos el símbolo del resistor es una
línea
zig zag así y esto lo que quiere
simbolizar esa es la corriente pasando
por aquí pero con cierta resistencia
teniendo que hacer algún trabajo otro
símbolo que se utiliza para denotar al
resistor en algunas otras partes del
mundo es un símbolo así ok estos son dos
símbolos que representan a los resistor
es y los asociamos con la letra r bueno
y ahora vamos con los símbolos de los
capacitores como estos generalmente
están construidos por dos objetos
metálicos o bueno por dos conductores
que se encuentran muy cerca el uno del
otro
utilizamos este símbolo porque además
los capacitores cuando los construimos
en efecto se ven más o menos así y la
letra asociada con los capacitores es la
letra c
ahora finalmente vamos con los
inductores los inductores generalmente
están hechos por una espiral de alambre
por lo que es un símbolo es este y la
letra que utilizamos es la l lo cual
puede parecernos bastante extraño porque
lo más lógico sería ponerle una perola y
la vamos a utilizar como la letra para
la corriente y le pusimos la letra i a
la corriente por un término en francés
que se refiere a la intensidad y además
no lo podíamos poner la letra c porque
eso se refiere a los capacitores así es
que hay que tomar en cuenta que esta
nomenclatura tiene sus detalles
importantes pero bueno antes de eso
vamos a ver una convención muy
importante acerca de cómo se dibujan los
voltajes y las corrientes en los
circuitos cuando estemos hablando del
voltaje en alguno de estos componentes
podemos empezar poniendo un signo de más
en donde queramos y luego ponemos el
signo menos
de voltaje la corriente que está
fluyendo a través de este componente
aunque ya la corriente siempre la
denotamos por la letra y ok vamos a
dibujarla en estos dos también la
corriente siempre llega del lado
positivo del elemento
y tenemos por aquí el voltaje y la
corriente siempre entra del lado
positivo del componente eso es muy
importante tenemos que ser muy
consistentes con esto para no cometer
ningún error pero bueno cada uno de
estos componentes tiene una ecuación que
asocia al voltaje con la corriente y en
el caso de los resistor es esta ecuación
nos dice que el voltaje es igual a la
corriente
r el voltaje a través del resistor es
igual a la corriente a través del
resistor x
esta constante de proporcionalidad a la
que le llamamos la resistencia y ahora
esta ecuación de aquí tiene un nombre
muy importante porque es una ecuación
muy importante y su nombre es la ley de
ohm
y vamos a estar utilizando esta ecuación
un montón esta es la ley de ohm bueno y
ahora vamos a ver la ecuación que
relaciona al voltaje y a la corriente
que está relacionada con los capacitores
y bueno los capacitores tienen la
característica de que la corriente es
proporcional no al voltaje sino a la
velocidad de cambio del voltaje aunque
haya la tasa de cambio del voltaje y eso
se escribe de esta manera aunque tenemos
por aquí la corriente que es igual a c y
se es la constante de proporcionalidad y
finalmente tenemos que poner por aquí la
velocidad de cambio del voltaje pero eso
se escribe como debe d
aunque esto también se conoce como la
tasa de cambio del voltaje con respecto
al tiempo multiplicamos a esta velocidad
de cambio por la constante de
proporcionalidad de este capacitor y
esta constante se llama la capacitancia
y eso nos tiene que dar la corriente
esta ecuación no tiene un nombre en
específico pero me voy a estar
refiriendo a esta ecuación como la
ecuación del capacitor pero bueno
finalmente vamos con la tercera ecuación
la ecuación para los inductores los
inductores tienen una característica
bastante similar a la de los capacitores
pero al revés el voltaje a través del
inductor es directamente proporcional a
la velocidad de cambio de la corriente
ok el voltaje es proporcional a la tasa
de cambio con respecto al tiempo de la
corriente y eso se escribe así el
voltaje es igual
a él por de y con respecto al tiempo el
voltaje es proporcional y esta es la
constante de proporcionalidad a la que
le llamamos inductancia aunque ya está
es la inductancia de este inductor y
esto de aquí es la velocidad de cambio
de la corriente la tasa de cambio con
respecto al tiempo de la corriente a lo
largo del inductor y listo ya tenemos
aquí a nuestras tres ecuaciones las tres
ecuaciones de los componentes de los
circuitos y cómo te puedes imaginar las
vamos a estar usando muchísimo todo el
tiempo siempre que estemos analizando
circuitos estas ecuaciones van a estar
en el meollo del asunto pero ahora hay
otras dos cosas de las que tenemos que
hablar para empezar tenemos que hablar
acerca de las fuentes lo que tenemos que
hablar de las fuentes de voltaje y de
corriente porque pues todo esto tiene
que venir de algún lugar y tenemos estos
dos tipos de fuentes que proporcionan
energía y potencia y señal
de entrada el circuito que estamos
tratando de construir porque tenemos la
fuente de voltaje y tenemos la fuente de
corriente eléctrica también conocida
como fuente de intensidad eléctrica pero
por el momento le vamos a llamar
corriente y bueno por supuesto que
tenemos distintos símbolos para las
fuentes de voltaje y de corriente para
las fuentes de voltaje tenemos dos
símbolos y uno de ellos es un círculo
con un símbolo de más y de menos y
también por aquí una letra de ahora otra
forma de dibujar una fuente de voltaje
sobre todo si la fuente es una batería
lo dibujamos de esta forma ok
así se dibujan las baterías también
tiene un ave por acá y la convención en
este símbolo es que este es el lado que
tiene la línea larga o sea que es
es la terminal positiva hoy por aquí
está el voltaje positivo y por acá el
negativo este es el lado negativo pero
bueno aquí en este otro símbolo
dibujamos directamente el símbolo de más
y de menos y quiero que te acostumbres a
dibujarlos para recordar que esta es una
propiedad de esta fuente y por acá en
este otro símbolo la línea larga es el
lado positivo y la línea corta es el
lado negativo y por supuesto ponemos el
voltaje en estos dos componentes del
circuito de la misma forma que en estos
otros tres componentes tenemos el más el
menos y la ve y la corriente entra por
aquí y podemos poner por aquí también el
voltaje
- d
la corriente entra por acá
esta es la conversión universal de cómo
se denota en estas cosas pero bueno
ahora vamos con la corriente una fuente
de corriente es una fuente de constante
corriente y la dibujamos de esta forma
pero aquí adentro del círculo dibujamos
una flecha que es la corriente y que nos
indica en qué dirección está fluyendo la
corriente y además le ponemos el nombre
si es una fuente constante de corriente
usamos la letra mayúscula y de la misma
forma si es una fuente constante de
voltaje utilizamos la letra mayúscula b
y otra vez ponemos por aquí el voltaje
más menos cualquiera que sea ese voltaje
podemos no saberlo y dejar simplemente
la be y en este caso la corriente va en
esta dirección
así es que finalmente tenemos aquí los
cinco componentes que vamos a utilizar
para crear circuitos ahora otra cosa muy
importante que quiero decir ahorita es
que tanto estas ecuaciones como estas
fuentes de voltaje y de corriente y
estos tres componentes son ideales y de
'la es así es que estamos tratando a
todo esto como si fueran objetos
matemáticos perfectos
ok son cosas que tenemos en nuestras
cabezas y que vamos a tratar de
construir en el mundo real y la verdad
es que nos vamos a acercar bastante
aunque hoy vamos a estar muy cerca de
los componentes ideales
estas ecuaciones se refieren a esos
modelos ideales de lo que vamos a
construir y si todo fuera perfecto como
nuestros componentes ideales entonces si
ve es igual a iu por r y es igual a c x
debe entre de t y b es igual a l por d /
dt en fin estas ecuaciones van a
terminar siendo como policía para ti muy
pronto y con estas ecuaciones ideales
vamos a poder construir todo tipo de
circuitos súper interesantes así es que
ya tenemos por aquí todo el conjunto de
elementos que podemos utilizar para
crear circuitos en los próximos vídeos
vamos a ver cada uno de estos elementos
con mucho detalle y vamos a aprender
algunas otras cosas acerca de ellos y
luego los vamos a empezar a combinar
para crear estos circuitos interesantes
así es que nos vemos pronto